this morning we're excited to announce
one of this nfl season's premiere
matchups in a rare game on christmas day
airing right here on cbs where the
sprite here on cbs gayle the super bowl
champion los angeles rams will host the
new look denver broncos and new
quarterback russell wilson and while
it's a little early to make any
projections russell i can almost
guarantee it this game will have some
playoff implications and i will also be
hosting a special slime filled
family-friendly broadcast of the game on
nickelodeon i'll be in the booth for
that along with a few other nickelodeon
favorites and we have nfl today's bill
cower right here let me say it again
hall of fame coach bill cower is joining
us right now to talk about that game and
what he's looking forward to in this nfl
season what's going on coach how you
doing how are you doing today i'm good
and i got to tell you the nickelodeon
game that you guys have put on at
thanksgiving and this year on christmas
has been unbelievable and you're talking
about energy entertaining and educating
the young people yeah simplif you
simplify the game you make it fun it has
the best message you can give to the
little people i know my grandkids watch
it and we're looking forward to seeing
it on the christmas day hey i was going
to ask you about that i don't even need
to talk about that but let's talk about
the game though you know you have the
los angeles rams coming off of a super
bowl question russell wilson how about
that trade in the offseason he is now
the quarterback for the denver denver
broncos what do you think about that
game well you know number one you think
about the last time the demo broncos won
a championship what they do they went
out and got a veteran quarterback who
had won a super bowl that was peyton
manning right so now all of a sudden you
go to seattle a veteran quarterback
who's won the super bowl they've been
looking for that quarterback coming into
a division now you put him in there with
patrick holmes justin herbert and derek
carr that the afc west is loaded this
year and that game's gonna be ideal
we'll see where he is in december yeah
see how much he understands and he's in
flow with that offense but the rams
looking to repeat
cooper cup matthew stafford aaron donald
a lot of slime will be thrown around
that game
you're right about that what's going on
with tom brady coming out of retirement
now i mean approach after 40-something
days yeah approaching his mid-40s right
i mean he's getting up there at age how
impressed are you that he was able to
keep his body together to perform at a
near mvp level and were you surprised
that he came back so quickly well you
know what gail i think at the end of the
season i think he did what a lot of
people should do is take a step back i
think we need more of a little bit of a
time frame to sit back to reflect to put
a perspective on it that's not just
coming off of a four-month season and i
think when you look at tom brady the
fact that last year he led the ligand
yards led the ligand touchdowns he was
only sacked 22 times probably playing as
good he's ever played they put another
group of people around him that he
hasn't lost anybody they're still the
best team in their division why not come
back you know so if you think about this
right because your wife doesn't want you
to you know what i think after it was
after four weeks he said he's coming
back his wife probably said go back
after him hearing honey do the dishes he
was like you know what i'm going to
throw this football around real quick
and what about the nfl going to germany
the nfl is going overseas you know i
think gail when they added 17 games
part of that process brady and the
buccaneers they're they're going to
germany the next four years they're
going to play two in frankfurt and two
in munich but they're going overseas a
lot going to mexico city this year for a
regular season game so i think when you
have that 17th game a chance to expand
the national football league globally is
a lot part of what the idea was when
they did that and i think one of my
takeaways in this year i was to say this
when you think about the last two super
bowls
tom brady yep icon in new england yep
goes down to tampa bay yep wins the
super bowl
last year matthew stafford icon in
detroit
goes to the rams yeah wins the super
bowl yeah who is this year's i'm going
to make a prediction right here okay how
about matt ryan
going from atlanta uh-huh going to
indianapolis
with jonathan taylor and frank wright
what have they been looking for the last
two years or the defense that's intact
could this be three consecutive years
you know how the league is kind of
copycat league
could this be the next one i don't think
i like it
all right well listen we have to go but
speaking about retirement will we ever
see you coach again uh i coach every
sunday uh nate i haven't lost the game
in 16 years
i don't know
about it they're handing out some big
checks around here man fair question no
no no you know what i really love the
platform we have at cbs we have some of
the best games
in the world but cbs right now is loaded
with great quarterbacks josh allen
patrick mahomes the afc west all right
and you know what working with this guy
every sunday
with uh hey pleasure
phil and jb we have got a great group
great chemistry and i enjoy going to
work every sunday
keep going coach all right
no car we appreciate you man can't wait
to work with you on sundays once the
season starts the full 2022 nfl schedule
will be revealed this thursday at 8 pm
eastern on the nfl network and paramount
plus